hello everybody my name is nayan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're going to talk about why
you're not getting interviews
yeah yes we are talking about that we're
talking about how to best
optimize your resume so you can make
sure you do
get that call so let's get to it number
one
the first reason you're not getting
interviews is because there are no
keywords in your resume now what do i
mean by keywords
in the job posting that the company said
the posting you are applying to
you have no matching keywords from what
they stated
as their qualifications or their
responsibilities for the role etc
none of those words they use are on your
resume and this is really important
because
increasingly a i is what's being used
to filter through that first round of
applications
and so it's going to along with other
things
it's going to look to see what keywords
are being used and if
your keywords matches the keywords on
that
posting and this is a very easy fix
truly
just pull up that job posting look under
the qualifications and the
responsibilities
and seriously just copy and paste those
words in those phrases
now like let's make sure we're not lying
though let's make sure we're not lying
all i'm saying
is make sure that if you say you are
interested in front-end development
in your resume and in the job posting it
says
must have experience in react
now instead of saying front-end
development say react specifically
if if that is what you've used so i'm
not saying to lie i'm saying
make sure the way they are phrasing
things the words they are using if it
matches with you
and your experience make sure you use
those
exact words and phrases number two
you are not getting interviews because
your address
is on your resume this is something
i didn't know about until long after i
was done applying but
it's something i've heard from multiple
people from multiple recruiters
and pop up when i do look for resume
tips and advice and that is
don't put your address or your location
at all
on your resume and that's because
companies if they can avoid it
won't want to pay for relocation
yeah it's crazy and so when they see an
address
so far off from where their
company is based or where the job will
be based it's
and it can sometimes be an immediate
no for them now that being said i'm not
saying don't get that relocation
and everything but get the job first
get the job first and then when talking
negotiation and salary and benefits and
just the whole offer package bring up
relocation
if you need that if you aren't in that
state or anywhere
near there then bring up relocation but
yes the goal of the all of this is to
just make sure
you get that interview first make sure
you then get that job first because it's
a lot easier to say no
to a piece of paper than it is to say no
to somebody you just spent
weeks and sometimes months recruiting
and now you liked them they liked you
you gave them the job and then now oh i
need x amount of money for relocation
it's a lot harder
to just be like no no and then goodbye
because that's a lot of resources that
they
spend on you on recruiting measures
etc and if they can lock you down they
will try their best
to do that so take your address off your
resume and then
once you get the job bring that topic of
relocation
benefits stipends up number three
in your resume you are being too team
minded
you're saying we everywhere everywhere
we are my team or the company you
aren't saying i me
this is what i did and on one hand of
course you want to show that
you are team minded you are a team
player and you work well
in groups and you have experience
working in groups
but they're not hiring the group
they're not hiring the group they're
hiring you and this is of course
a habit that can be hard to break
because depending on what culture you're
in the idea is oh you don't talk about
yourself you don't talk about yourself
if someone compliments you you end up
you know
boasting up the team as a whole you
don't take credit for yours
like it's a whole sometimes it can be a
whole thing and so on your resume
having to then switch up and be like me
me me me
it can be difficult but yes do not shy
away from saying
no i got that deal and i brought in
x amount of dollars i put up this new
technology
this new xyz be
that person and it's okay to mention
your team
but bring the focus back to you so say
something like
part of the xyz team where i
brought in this this this where i
implemented this technology
and brought the team x so you can
mention it and show you have experience
in a team
but then leave that and bring the focus
back to you and this also applies to
interviews
don't constantly say oh my team did this
my team did this
what did you do but we'll get to that in
a different video if you like this one
and so let me know if you do
number four you are not getting
interviews because you are not
quantifying
your accomplishments now it's one thing
to say
brought in a lot of money for my company
rather than brought in two million
dollars
over two quarters during the x and x
establishment or whatever do you see how
the second one has a lot more
power to it because it's tangible it's
it's one thing to be like oh i brought
in a lot of x y and z it's like
it's easy to brush that off it's easy to
be just
see that and say okay okay but when you
see the numbers and the number doesn't
even need to be huge it doesn't need to
be two million
brought in 200 dollars per quarter
just add some type of number worked on a
six member team
where i accomplished x so make sure
you where you can can quantify things
don't beat around the bush y'all when it
comes to resumes when it comes to
interviews
don't beat around the bush say exactly
what you did when you did it how you did
it share
all of those things because it really
really can make all the difference in
the application and recruitment
process and then lastly number five this
is something that
gets a bit of controversy i will say
i sometimes do hear different things
from different people
but it is do not put your gpa
on your resume now this tip applies more
to the younger folks
if you are just coming out of college or
something like that or you don't have
much work experience
out of college and you're really relying
a lot on the education piece
of your resume don't put your gpa on
there
now this is something that if you had
asked me
i would not have given this advice to be
completely honest with you
but i have heard from multiple
recruiters
that this is something in terms of tips
to make sure you get through that door
this is something that you need to avoid
unless your dpa
is ridiculously high to not put it
because
it's really then only used to discount
you yeah because again we're thinking
about that computer and if that computer
sees a certain number they're not going
to say oh
well they took integrated physiology
and they took calculus five and so it's
okay that their gpa is lower because
they really applied themselves
a computer and aai is not going to see
that and
to draw that conclusion a human might
but like i said so many companies are
using ai for that initial screening now
and so we want to tailor our resume
primarily to that and so
take your gpa off and then if it is
brought up in an interview again let's
say you're a student or
you are very newly graduated student and
so the company you're interviewing for
might care about that if it's brought up
then share it
but like i said we want them to like you
first we want them to see you talk to
you like you first
and then ask and if it's a number lower
than what they would want they still
have all of this stuff
all of these conversations with you all
of these
insights into who you are as a person to
outweigh
that maybe negative aspect of your
application
but we're trying to get there we're
trying to get to that interview so take
it off your resume
unless it is ridiculously hot don't ask
me
what i think a ridiculously high number
is again to be honest i have my gpa
on my resume constantly constantly
constantly
and i just stopped this a few
months ago because i always thought it
was something that
i would be discounted for not having but
recruiters say otherwise in terms of
their hacks and tricks
they say otherwise and sometimes on the
application it will ask what your gpa
was i did go through applications like
that so if it
asks you what it is i'm not saying lie
put it on there if it doesn't ask
leave it just leave it by the end of the
day do what's best for you
it is your professional journey that
you're going through so who am i to say
to go against your gut don't
ever go against your gut you do you i'm
just giving you some insights and some
tips but the main thing i
really want you all to take away from
all of this is
passing that a i test passing that
initial
screening and a lot of times this will
be the reason you're not getting
interviews because you're not passing
the
ai portion so if you are about to start
applying to jobs or you're currently
applying to jobs
pull up your resume pull up your resume
and ask yourself
if it does pass that test and if it
doesn't make some changes
and i know it's so hard to change your
resume constantly to make sure the
keywords match with each individual job
and all this i know
it's so much work and it can be so
tiring and so
discouraging knowing you have to do all
of this just to be
seen but at the end of the day
sometimes we still have to just play
that game and do these things
so that we can secure that
job so there we go everybody i hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please
like and subscribe and i'll talk to you
later bye